trying to make me be like you well I'm
not going to be like you when it comes
to princesses of the animated variety
Disney pretty much invented the concept
speaking of concept these royal gals
didn't originally appear as we see them
on screen let's take a look at how these
ladies were first imagined Ariel
did you know Ariel was not originally a
gender Disney animators went back and
forth with blonde strawberry blonde and
eventually settled on red Disney
animator and concept artist Glen Keane
was charged with Ariel's look he
credited actress Alyssa Milano for
Ariel's characteristics and to capture
her underwater flowing hair
he studied footage of astronaut Sally
Ride when she was in space he also likes
to joke that his wife looks exactly like
Ariel but without the fins Ariel's been
part of three different worlds sea land
and space what is it I don't know but I
bet it's got a lil
Rapunzel the task of conceptualizing
Rapunzel was passed down to Glen Keane
starter Claire Keane
she described her process for
understanding Rapunzel by keeping a
journal of things she did all day at
home which she then used as inspiration
for Rapunzel's world as she states on
her website Claire on a cloud calm it
helped me see her as a real person who
lived beyond the scenes and plot points
of the movie she looks a bit more
serious perhaps more burdened with her
secluded world
jazzmin Aladdin's first love wasn't
Jasmin but his own mother
yes Aladdin was a mama's boy while
Jasmin played a more minor role there
you go
you'd better be able to pay for that
minor but tougher after the mommy
storyline was scrapped she was moved
into the spotlight but lost some of her
spunk this pink girl image was also
scrapped that's a lot of pink what all
was said and done Jasmine's whole look
was basically inspired by the famous
mausoleum of the Taj Mahal Ana at first
glance
there doesn't seem to be much difference
between Ana's before and after however
if you look closely at the two faces
earlier drafts gave her sharper features
with a pointy turned up nose the real
difference is the original storyline
Anna and Elsa did not start out as
sisters but as potential rivals
[Applause]
we'll get to Elsa's dramatic change
shortly it's pretty dramatic Elsa Elsa
almost wasn't a princess but a villain
in this version there is no relation
between Anna and Elsa in fact Anna asks
evil Elsa to freeze her heart to get
over an ex somewhere along the way
screenwriter Jennifer Lee started to
really feel for Elsa's situation in the
story of frozen making a Disney animated
classic she reveals you care about
someone who's been forced to hide who
they are
Elsa's done a villain she just makes
some bad choices because she's in a very
difficult situation once that was
decided the production team began to
focus on Elsa's fear of her power and
her loneliness Aurora the princess shall
indeed grow in grace and beauty Sleeping
Beauty took 6 to 9 years to complete in
that time Aurora went from a
raven-haired hottie to a whimsical
graceful yet extremely drowsy princess
we've come to love Marc Davis well known
for his skills with the leading ladies
Aurora was the first princess with
violent eyes and her features were
mainly inspired by Audrey Hepburn which
explains the
black hair Merida the refinements Givens
Merida between original concept sketches
and the final product weren't as
dramatic as we've seen on this list
animators at Pixar gave her specific
features for a specific purpose
Brenda Chapman describes Merida with an
athletic figure to match her energy and
wild spirit she gave her wide-set eyes
instead of huge round eyes as well as
around her face I wanted to give her a
design where you could look at her and
say girl but there was an appeal to it
that's why fans took notice when Disney
revealed their own version of the
princess Mulan several animators
supervisors were sent to Mulan Mulan was
an important film for animators as this
was no ordinary princess the father's
who worked on the film wanted to give
their daughters a hero who fought her
own battles they determined from the
beginning she would need no Prince to
save her first given the common feminine
attributes as other princesses they
eventually curved the curves to make her
more believable posing as a man joining
the army she was never a girly girl in
the first place Khan let's go home
Belle Papa do you think I'm odd the
princess makes smart look good but we
may have never heard this girl belt out
her tunes
can you imagine Beauty and the Beast
without music with a much darker story
neither can we but that's how this movie
almost became in that version Bella was
given black hair which would have likely
fit in the darker version of the script
to lighten her up they lightened her
hair softened her facial features and
dressed her in her iconic blue dress
Jane Porter this princess makes smart
look good host Oh Jane Porter's first
looks didn't reflect her carefree and
curious personality she came across as a
little more proper or shall we say
uppity her final look was softened with
quirky expression
and mannerisms more fitting for a
curious scientist as well as mini driver
who brought miss Potter to life and
served as the perfect model Alice mr.
rabbit Alice in Wonderland is a wild
ride with the most unusual characters I
suppose he must have however
animators had difficulty adapting Mary
Blair's concept art saying her style was
too flat they found it challenging they
were able to bring life to Alice her
work eventually proved immensely
valuable when drawing inspiration
animators took notice of various
attributes in Mary's concept art these
attributes included color selection use
of lighting and costume design
Pocahontas the real Pocahontas was only
11 or 12 years old when John Smith came
to town
naturally Disney animators first
considered portraying her at this age
and pitched an image of Tiger Lily from
Peter Pan the young adult we saw in
screens was due to the success of the
epic romantic tale of Beauty and the
Beast and executives decided to ride
that lovey-dovey wave by aging our
courageous princess for John Smith to
fall in love with when will I see you
again leaving tonight right here
Cinderella
can't tell
cuz if you tell a wish it won't come
true Mary Blair makes another appearance
with her concept of cinderelly she had
been sent to South America in 1941 and
was inspired by the imagery of her
surroundings Walt was so impressed by
her style he entrusted her with many
films including Cinderella oh I
understand but it's more than I ever
hoped for Snow White magic let's go back
to the beginning where it all started
the og princess the one who proved to
skeptics who said an hour-long animated
feature couldn't be done being that this
had never been done before they faced
the challenge of making sure the
characters didn't look artificial in
fact that is why we don't see the Prince
much they focused all their efforts on
myths no Disney brought in actors to
perform the scenes to inspire the
animators the actress who portrays Snow
White was none other than Hedy Lamarr
Tinker Bell if you thought the tink was
sassy on screen just take a look at an
earlier concept of the redheaded pixie
since she doesn't speak the animators
gave her strong expressions to speak her
mind The Pixies look resembled popular
pin-up girls of the time she's even been
compared to Marilyn Monroe which Disney
Princess makeover was your favorite
let's get out of here you're not getting
cold fins now are you did any surprise
you what's your take on Elsa let us know
in the comment section and thanks for
watching the things
[Music]